With over $23 million in deals
and an estimated 9,000 jobs
created to date,
"Shark Tank" is a phenomenon.
And now we're back
with a brand-new season.
This is the "Shark Tank."
There's nothing else like it
on earth.
Boom!
With more mind-blowing ideas...
This is what we created.
(sharks) wow!
And as you can see,
in a matter of seconds,
you're making power.
Whoa!
That dog has a bow tie on.
That's insane.
Oh, gosh.
(man) Oh, let's go, let's go.
Get through this.
Oh, look at that.
He's already coming back.
(laughter)
Are you guys ready
for something good?
(women) ♪ spread it,
mix it, shake it, stir it ♪
ha ha ha!
What I'm about to show you
is incredible.
You're like a freak of nature.
Hi-Yah!
Life-changing offers.
What if I give you $500,000?
I'll do $600,000...
800k.
We're making you an offer
for $1 million.
Don't mistake my kindness
for weakness.
This is a defining moment.
You're only gonna be
on that carpet once.
Okay, my last offer--
$4 million.
(laughs)
And more bite than ever.
Give the guy a break.
This is business.
Are we gonna hold hands
and sing "Kumbaya" here?
Oh, stop it.
That shows how little
he understands.
Let me finish talking, Mark.
Enough!
What should we toast to?
Pitching to the sharks.
Sometimes it ends badly,
though.
I'm gonna give it to you
straight.
Worst pitch I've ever seen.
It's dead.
You're keeping it alive
on life support, and it's cruel.
Let me kill it for you.
You don't have to look.
I take offense
to that comment.
Do you realize how bad
you just screwed up?
I just think you're being a bully.
I mean,
they might be misguided.
Okay, I am being a bully,
then they deserve to be bullied.
You know, NBA should stand for
"Needs a better attitude."
(Daymond) Whoa!
(laughs)
And tonight
for the first time ever,
Barbara Corcoran
and Lori Greiner together.
What Lori does well
is she sells product.
What I do well
is build power brands.
Oh, that's not true at all.
You can't get a word in
Edgewise.
Barbara, when did you become
the teacher of the day? (laughs)
Why do you have to have
the royalty on this?
Just drop it.
You know, Barbara,
I might have done that...
it's unfair.
(Robert) Stop.
Both of you, stop.
It's like a gunfight
at the O.K. Corral.
And it all begins... right now.
How do I make money?
(voice echoes)
♪♪
First into the tank is
a tech-savvy entrepreneur
with a modern way to send
a traditional postcard.
♪♪
Hi, sharks.
My name is Josh Brooks.
I'm the founder
of on the run tech
and postcard on the run.
Today I'm seeking $300,000
in exchange for 5% equity
in my company.
If you're anything like me,
you've got 22,000 photos
stashed away on a hard drive,
another thousand
Cluttering up your phone.
Maybe put it up on facebook
for 13 seconds,
e-mail 'em to a friend,
and ba-bam, they're gone.
They deserve more. Our product
is the answer to this.
It's called
postcard on the run.
Take a picture from wherever
you are in the world.
Write a quick note.
Sign it with your finger,
and send it to anywhere
in the world
right from the convenience
of your mobile phone.
And what do you get?
Voilà. A beautiful 4x6
glossy personalized note
that arrives in the mail
in a matter of days.
We live a life on the run.
This product helps us connect
better than We've ever
connected in the world.
Sharks, we've got a platform
product. Today it's postcards.
Tomorrow it's
a tremendous amount more.
Join me today
in the memory business, guys.
So we actually got
some mail for you.
I love getting mail.
It's fun.
Special for you.
It's fun. Oh, thank you.
(Lori) Aw! (laughs)
Thank you.
All right.
(Barbara) Wow, great.
Thanks, Josh.
You bet.
So let's go through what this
postcard actually really is.
So we got
a beautiful 4x6 photo.
Then on the back
you write a simple note.
We built a telestrator.
So you actually
take your finger, sign it,
so it's really you, Robert,
and then
a really great feature.
This is my my daughter
Leni Brooks.
This was actually
a thank-You note to her grandma.
You scan it with your, uh,
your--your mobile device.
Right here.
It's a Q.R. code.
And ba-bam. Now you got
a short little video.
Take a look.
♪ Thank you, thank you,
thank you ♪
♪ thank you,
thank you, thank you ♪
(laughs)
♪ Thank you ♪
I'm in Italy.
I wanna send a postcard.
I go to my phone.
Mm-hmm.
I capture a picture.
Correct.
I send it.
Walk me through what happens
on the back end now.
So--
How does that get mailed?
Sure. You're in Italy.
You take the picture.
You write the simple note.
You change the color,
change the font.
Okay.
You sign it with your finger,
right?
Then it brings you
to your address book, right?
Right. That was one
of my questions.
I don't think I have
any physical addresses.
That's right.
We built a product
called postal gopher,
which is our patent pending
address retrieval technology
that allows the user to send
a postcard to somebody
with only having
their e-Mail or cell.
My system alerts you,
"Hey, Mark, your friend
Josh Brooks is trying
to send you a postcard."
Oh, that's cool.
Is there a novelty to it,
though?
You know, you send one
to grandma and grandpa,
and then you send it again
and then you send it again,
and then it's sort of like,
"Oh, another postcard."
I mean, do you find the--
it--there's a--
Uh, I don't think you're
gonna find any of that.
In fact, the people that are
on the receiving end
of these postcards--
Postcard fatigue.
Honestly, $2.49--goose bumps
are totally included,
and that's what ends up
happening.
(Robert) Okay, Josh,
walk me through the money.
How do I pay for it?
How do you make money?
So it's a free application,
but it's $2.49 per postcard.
What are your margins after
you've paid all the royalties
on the databases you're using?
We built all of our databases.
There are no royalties.
Do you own this business
yourself?
That's correct. I actually have
a group of investors as well.
You do.
Uh, I did. I raised
a little bit of capital
to get this off the ground.
Keep in mind, I put 30,000 bucks
of my own money
to get this thing going.
And what is your background that
you've come up with this idea?
I used to run marketing
for myspace
during the good days
for three and a half years.
What are your sales?
That's all that really matters.
Sure. So in the 21 months,
we've done $450,000 in revenue.
Okay, and you've made...
(Robert) Wow.
How much money on that?
Everything goes right back
into the company, 100%.
Josh, how many downloads
of the app do you have?
Just around 500,000, uh,
downloads of the application.
Josh, let's go back
to the investors for a sec.
How much money did you raise
in total?
We raised $1.6 million
in total.
And what was the valuation
of the 1.6 you raised
in the valley?
$6 million.
You're giving us the same value,
am I right?
That's right.
So, Josh, your strategy is
to run like hell
because there's nothing
proprietary here.
Anybody can do this.
Let's be honest with each other.
Well, being totally honest,
that is not correct.
It takes a tremendous amount
of ingenuity
to do what we did.
Okay, but--
Absolutely.
That's easy to do. There's tons
of people who do that.
This is not a one-winner
takes all.
This is about coming up
with a great product
that people absolutely love.
But that doesn't mean
it can't be replicated easily
by using third party products.
But that is the 1,000-Pound
postcard in the room.
Yeah, no, absolutely.
Josh, I'm telling you--
but the point being is that
we've hit the market.
We've got--If you look
at web sites,
if you look at bloggers,
you look at editorial,
and they talk about
"Hey, what's interesting
connecting the online
to offline?"
they're gonna point
to our product.
Here's the problem, Josh.
The concept of valuing this
at $6 million is ridiculous.
You live in
the silicon valley bubble,
and it's gonna burst.
Either you get acquired,
or you're out of luck,
because there's
no I.P.O. market anymore
for middle-sized companies
like yours,
so you have to get acquired.
I hear your point, right?
My point is this,
is that we haven't even
begun marketing, right?
I get that. Look, you fell
to the silicon valley curse.
If you were to come in here,
Saying, look,
"We gotta raise $200,000
or $300,000
at a $2 million valuation,"
then we can visualize,
okay, nice little business,
and we could sell it
for 6.
But you're already at 6.
Mark--
The problem is you've gotta
sell it big
to get any type of return
for us.
So I-I think what I have is
a great group of investors
that are super supportive
of us.
Josh, you could stay up
all night.
That doesn't mean
you're gonna get lucky, right?
Totally.
You've gotta get lucky
in order
for this to really work
for investors.
Absolutely.
You have to have an exit
that takes some luck,
and I just don't see it.
How much cash do you have
left in the bank?
We have $185,00
in the bank.
You're screwed. I'm out.
Out of $1.6 million,
you're down to $185,000?
$185,000, correct.
You're gonna blow up
in 90 days, you don't get cash.
You need to raise right now
this $300,000.
You are running like
that little postcard guy.
There is nothing proprietary
about what you're doing.
I'm not diminishing
your business.
I'm just telling you I could
do it for less than $6 million.
Absolutely not what I invest
in this. I'm out.
(Barbara) There's a couple
things I really like.
I like nothing better than
a friend sending me
an actual photograph.
I take hundreds of them
of my kids,
but I never print them out,
and there's a difference.
Exactly.
So when I get a photo
in the mail,
for me it's a present,
all right?
Mm-hmm.
The idea that I would get
also wrapped into that
a postcard is great.
I think of a postcard
as a present, too.
Sure.
Nobody sends them anymore,
and of your kid...
sure.
It's a win, all right?
Sure.
But there's something
that really disturbs me,
and that is
this postcard lacks
in the warm and fuzzy
emotional piece
which you're hard-selling here,
is that it's typefaced.
Can you scroll your whole
message or only your signature?
Today we can just do
your signature and a picture.
Well, that's a problem.
Tomorrow there's no reason
why we couldn't do any of that.
It takes the warm and fuzzy
out of it for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
Guys, we've got a business
that actually brings in money.
It's $450,000 in 21 months.
Yeah, but you have hardly
any money left.
We have not added any gasoline
to that flame at all.
So out of the downloads
or the users,
what's the age range?
Our target market
would be
somewhere in this
21-to-45-year-old female,
but my partner and investor
in the company is Selena Gomez.
Sorry. The Selena Gomez
that my kids love?
Totally.
Uh, she invested
in both rounds--
The angel round as well as
the seed round of financing.
My kids travel
all over the place.
I love my kids.
I miss my kids.
They never e-mail me.
They never text me.
I think my kids would use this.
They're always sending
pictures.
They never...
so what you're saying--
they won't take the time
to e-mail or text, but they're
gonna download an app,
take the picture,
and click "Send"?
Yeah, Mark,
because they know daddy--They
know that daddy would love it.
I think it's a great idea,
but, you know, you said,
"I have patents pending."
You don't know if
you're going to get it or not
and really get out there
fast and furious.
And for that reason, I'm out.
All right.
All right, who's left here?
Robert, I think.
Robert sees the vision.
Yeah, Josh,
I do see the vision.
But I kind of
agree with Mark.
Your value is
a silicon valley bubble,
and you'd have to sell
for an enormous amount
just to get some return.
Right.
I love the idea, though.
I think it's a great vision.
I appreciate that.
But... I'm not comfortable
with the $6 million valuation.
But I am comfortable
with a $3 million valuation.
So I'll do $300,000 for 10%.
I'm not sure
if I can do that.
♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Josh Brooks has one last chance
to make a deal.
I'm not comfortable
with a $6 million valuation.
But I am comfortable
with a $3 million valuation.
So I'll do $300,000 for 10%.
I'm not sure
if I can do that.
(Kevin) Tough decision, Josh.
It is.
It gives you another six months
of life.
Let me ask you this.
Would you consider doing
something more on the lines
of a $5 million valuation?
And that's 6% of your company.
Correct.
That allows me to keep
my current group of investors
that I have
a lot of respect for
and also, that 300k is going
right into the marketing.
After $1.6 million in 2 years,
you're down
to the last $180,000,
and the reason I think my money
brings the premium is
you can't survive
without that money.
Robert, you Savage,
are you gonna take advantage
of his situation just 'cause
he's running out of money?
You're gonna cut his knees off?
It's my money. I worked
really hard for my money.
I get the privilege of saying
what I feel it's worth.
Right.
So...
I'm comfortable with $3 million.
You're saying $5 million.
Now it's up to you.
I think the business lends
itself to something larger,
and I honestly really
appreciate
your enthusiasm
for the company,
but I can't take
that significant of a haircut
on the value
of the company.
(sighs) I'll ask you again.
What about something closer
to the $5 million range?
And even if it's at 4.8.
Find me at 4.8,
and let's do a deal.
Okay, my last offer--$4 million.
That's $300,000 for 7 1/2%.
I think
there's significant value
in having a shark onboard.
(exhales) Hone--
I really appreciate the offer.
I don't think at $4 million
of valuation, I can do that.
But the company
is more than that.
I swear it is. I know it is.
So you're not accepting
his offer.
Find me at 4.5, and let's make
this thing happen.
Listen, you're investing
in a guy that gets things done.
It took two years
to get where we are today--
Under two years.
Josh, the only guy up here
that believed in the vision
as soon as you came out
that saw it...
sure.
I mean, you've got a fan here
in the technology.
I think you've done it. Uh...
but not in the price.
You're not a fan of his price.
I'm not a fan of the price,
and that's my privilege
as a shark.
(sighs) $300,000
at a $4 million valuation--
is that what you're saying?
I'm saying $300,000 at--
For 7 1/2%,
which gives it
a $4 million valuation.
(sighs)
(sighs) Let's do the Deal.
Done.
That's awesome.
Good job, Robert.
Way to hold it out.
(Lori laughs)
Thanks, man.
Nice job today.
Appreciate it.
It's a--It's a great product.
Yeah.
It's awesome.
Thanks so much.
Yeah. Yeah.
Thank you.
Good job, Josh.
I appreciate it.
Yeah, good job, man.
(Mark) Congrats, Josh.
I think it's
a phenomenal idea.
I think it's a crapshoot.
I know there's products
similar...
you have to be acquired,
or you're going to zero.
(laughs)
♪♪
Last season,
mother and daughter team
Danielle Desroches
and Tracey Noonan
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their
jarred cupcake company,
Wicked Good Cupcakes.
♪ Come to mama ♪
(laughter)
Let's see
what they're doing now.
Business has been wicked good
since "Shark tank."
Our biggest news is
we were able to open
a second location in
Boston's iconic Faneuil Hall.
We also have a new bakery,
which is super exciting.
We have 40 more employees now,
and it just feels so good
to employ a lot of people.
Before airing on "Shark Tank,"
we had done $150,000 in sales
in 9 months.
After airing on "Shark Tank,"
We did $230,000 in sales
in one week.
We're up to $700,000
in sales,
and it looks like we'll close in
on $2 million this year.
That's a ton of money.
(laughs)
Ladies!
(Danielle) When we first
took the deal with Kevin,
it pretty much felt like we were
making a deal with the devil,
but he's like a little angel
in disguise.
$700,000 since the show.
And you've paid me back
my full $75,000.
That's what "Shark Tank's"
All about.
Those are huge numbers.
Our "Shark tank" Experience
was a big risk,
but a really well-Calculated
risk.
Everything that we worked
so hard to achieve
has been
completely validated.
All right,
I'm selling cupcakes.
Wicked good cupcakes.
The great thing
about "Shark tank"
is it changes lives.
When you back
a successful entrepreneur
and create 40 jobs,
you're creating the new America.
This is what it's all about.
♪♪
I'm Lynnae Schneller...
and I'm Aly Cullinane.
(both) And we're from
Tacoma, Washington.
(singsongy) Good morning, girls.
It's pickle time.
Whoo!
(laughter)
We run a gourmet,
high-end pickle business
based on
my great-grandma Toots'
100-year-old
secret family recipe.
Girls.
Lynnae's not kidding
when she says
it's a secret family recipe.
I had to wait seven years
to be married into the family
before learning the recipe.
(women shouting at once
and laughing)
(Lynnae, singsongy)
Who wants a pickle?
Come try a sample.
(Lynnae) Our pickles
are unlike any pickle
you've ever tried before.
They're crunchy, delicious,
and absolutely addicting.
This week we have three P.O.S
that we need to get ready
to put out.
Okay.
We need the sharks because
we need additional capital
in order to feed the growing
demand of our business.
We've risked everything
to start our business.
We quit our jobs
and put our careers on the line.
To grandma Toots.
(all) To grandma Toots!
We know that great-grandma toots
is looking down,
just so proud that
we're not only carrying on
our family tradition,
but we're bringing her recipe
to the world.
♪♪
Hi, sharks.
My name is Lynnae Schneller...
and my name is
Aly Cullinane.
And our company is
Lynnae's Gourmet Pickles.
We are seeking $125,000
in exchange for 20%
of our company.
We're sure you're all aware
that specialty food
is among the fastest-growing
industries in the U.S.
There is, however,
an unfulfilled niche
in specialty...
(both) pickles!
(chuckles)
After launching
in September 2011,
we had quick success,
and we're selling pickles
faster than we can make them.
Sharks, with all the uproar
we've caused,
we've got ourselves in a pickle
and need your help to feed
our increasing demand.
Lynnae is handing out
our two signature flavors.
They are Mrs. Pickles...
(Robert) Thank you.
Our original
sweet and sour dill,
and Hot Mama,
a sweet and sour dill...
Oh, thank you.
With a kick of jalapeño.
And did you tell us
what your sales were?
In the last 12 months,
they're $144,000,
which is 36,000 jars
of pickles.
Wow.
What does a jar cost?
Suggested retail price
is $6.99.
And what do you sell them
wholesale for?
Average--$4.
And what's your cost?
(Lori) and what does
it cost you to make?
Our cost is $1--
Our cost is $1.93.
So right now we have stores
that want our product.
We just don't have the money
to produce the inventory.
For inventory and producing,
yeah.
And where have you sold them?
We actually are available
in 26 states
and about 200 locations.
Amazing.
Yeah, but--
do you sell them yourself?
(Robert)
are you using a distributor?
We do.
We are using a distributor.
We're signed on with the largest
specialty food distributor
in the U.S.
You know, you're--
You're in a classic
entrepreneur's dilemma, right?
Yeah.
Because you don't
have enough inventory
to grow with the company, so--
but it's a good dilemma
to have.
(Lynnae and Aly) Yeah.
It's a good problem to have,
right?
But what I'm saying is
in order for us to invest,
we have to see beyond that.
Do you have anything
that's so differentiated,
people are gonna say,
"Wow"?
I wanna tell you
the answer for his question.
The differentiator
are the two of you.
What else do you do
to market the product
other than a fancy display?
We do really creative things.
We did the national pickle hunt
within our city last year
that was covered
both locally and nationally.
And that was your idea?
Yes.
Mm-hmm, and throughout the day,
there was little clues posted,
and whoever got there first
to find the jar
got a package worth
anywhere from $200 to $1,000.
The video footage
from the newscasts--
Literally people are running
down the streets of our city,
trying to find these jars,
and it was a huge success,
so we're planning
on doing that every year.
Chasing the big pickle.
(laughing)
Chasing the pickle, so...
look, we've seen food products,
but you've obviously
been very ambitious
and successful
in marketing this,
and I'm trying to figure out
how do I make money with this?
How do you scale the business?
We have--next month,
we have a meeting
with one of the largest
retailers in the U.S
because they just--
(Kevin) Who is that?
Target.
They came to us, though,
because they expanded
into grocery last year,
and now they want to expand
their specialty line.
That would be
a game-Changer for me.
(Lori) Yes.
If it works, then you're
in the big league.
I'm not sure you guys are gonna
be able to pull that off.
Our distribution channels
already deliver to Target.
I'm Target.
Tell me why
I should carry your pickles
over the other 20 other ones.
We really appeal to
a gourmet, high-end... market.
Is it reflected in your price?
Yeah, $6.99. Yeah.
Yeah, $6.99.
(Robert) is that--
the average--
How does that compare
to a normal pickle jar?
A normal pickle jar--
The average
is about $3, $3.50.
(Kevin) Wow.
But in specialty pickles--
Specialty pickles, though--
Twice.
Okay, ladies,
you just walked in
with huge risk.
$5.99, so it's $9.99.
Why would Target put a $7 jar in
when the market's at $3?
Because specialty food
has been growing by 22%
over the last several years.
You guys, I feel there are
a lot of competition
already out there.
I think you guys are wonderful,
but for me,
I don't like sweet pickles,
and I do have to like
whatever it is I invest in.
So I'm out on this one.
Thank you.
Guys, I think you have
a nice little business.
I think you guys hustle,
which is great.
You're creative.
And the big guys
aren't paying attention to you
because you're $144,000
in sales.
You--You don't matter to them.
But as you grow,
and you will,
they'll start paying attention.
They'll make a decision.
"do I buy them?"
you're not big enough.
"do I crush them
by just putting out
a comparable product?"
probably, and for that reason,
I'm out.
We know that
with any type of food,
there really is never
anything proprietary
Because someone Can create
something similar,
so our plan is to explode
into the market
and gain as much distribution
as we can,
and we do actually have interest
from several large--
Large stores.
No one's beating you up yet
because you're--You're so nice,
but now it's my chance
to do that, so I'm going to.
You're not worth over $600,000.
I don't think you can sell this
stuff at target at 7 bucks.
That's my personal opinion.
And the other issue for me
is do I want pickles
in my portfolio?
That's what I've been debating.
(Mark laughs)
And I don't think
the answer's "yes" to that,
so I'm out.
Any other questions or concerns
we can address for you?
I think you have two sharks
still left,
and Barbara's a sucker
for people selling food
in funny dresses.
I'm not a sucker at all.
I'm a sucker for
a great entrepreneur,
which obviously you both are.
Well, here's--
Here's what happens here.
We started with
great-Grandma's secret recipe,
and that was the passion
that started this business.
No food background.
We've grown so much
in the past two years.
Our potential is unlimited.
Aly, there's--There's no doubt
you guys have done a great job.
But $7 for a jar of pickles?
Yeah--
can I just reiterate
that the average range
is $5.99 to $9.99
for any specialty pickle?
So I'm croatian.
Croatians love pickles.
But very rare that they eat
sweet pickles.
I'm--I'm not the right investor.
I'm out.
All right, thank you.
Barbara.
(sighs)
Couple of things.
I think $144,000 in sales in
your first year is phenomenal.
There are very few
young entrepreneurs
that can make that claim.
So you don't need
any help here.
You're well on your road
to success,
and you regret selling
your chunk of your business
five years from now.
I almost made that mistake once
selling half my business
for $80,000, and thank god
that Investor changed his mind,
'cause I sold it for $66 million
5 years later.
I don't think you need
a partner, so I'm out.
Great. Thank you.
♪♪
(Aly) I think their comments
were very constructive.
We're gonna take everything
they said and really
think about
all their suggestions
and figure out, like, what
makes sense for our business.
♪♪
Next up are two doctors
from Tucson, Arizona,
with an idea
to innovate communication
in the medical field.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Dr. Amini.
And I'm Dr. Amini.
We're brothers,
and we're both physicians.
I'm Richard.
And I'm Albert.
(laughs)
Our company's Rolodoc,
and we're seeking
$50,000 for 20% of our company.
And as physicians,
we're constantly communicating
with our peers, our patients,
and with other
medical professionals.
And what we've realized
is that when it comes
to communication,
medicine is not
in the 21st century.
I mean, for crying out loud,
we're still using pagers
to communicate.
What is this, the '80s?
Rolodoc is the cure
for the old school communication
that exists in medicine.
Rolodoc allows for secure
e-mail between patients,
physicians,
and other medical professionals.
The mobile app allows for
instant messaging between them.
Take a look at this
sample patient profile.
Here's Mr. Wonderful's page.
He's entered in his information,
including his medical problems.
He looks good.
It looks like he's suffering
from a heart condition--
Acardia.
(laughs)
For those non-medical nerds,
this is a condition
when a person is literally born
without a heart.
Not to worry, Mr. Wonderful,
because you can then search
for physician by state,
specialty, or insurance
provider. Let's pick surgery.
Choosing surgery in Arizona
lets you find
this young,
good-looking surgeon.
You can then view his profile
and send him a message.
The surgeon receives
the message Instantly
and can reply
at his convenience.
Sharks, with your investment,
we will revolutionize the way
we communicate in medicine,
but most importantly, you'll
help us get rid of these pagers
and make some money
doing it.
Is the point that you can
personally communicate
to the doctors
that you have online?
Because doctors
Could be inundated
with e-Mails
and personal messages.
How would they ever
keep up with it?
What we're really trying to do
is bring social media
and the social network
to the medical profession.
What's the social element?
You didn't really say.
So... you--Let's say--
Let's say
Kevin O'Leary moves to L.A.,
wants to find a plastic surgeon
there,
get even sexier than he is
already.
I don't need that.
I look fantastic.
(laughter)
(Albert) even sexier.
I'm gonna have a heart attack
listening to that nonsense.
If he wants to go
find a doctor right now,
he's gonna do a search engine.
He's gonna be inundated
with inaccurate information,
and he's really gonna be--
end up just as confused
as when he started.
Are you up and running
at all?
We--we are in alpha testing
right now.
We've got 50 users on it--
Our personal connections
that are using it,
verifying how it works,
how the--
50 doctors
or just total users?
Total users.
(Kevin) I'm just looking
at my own situation.
My doctor's in Boston.
When I have aches and pains
and I'm on the road,
I can e-mail him as I do.
He communicates back to me
that way
and suggests that I go see
a specialist when I get home,
all done by e-mail.
The organization in Boston
which has my medical files
shares them amongst hospitals.
We've got that technology now.
So when I arrive
at the specialist,
they have all my history.
They know who I am.
What are you adding
to that equation?
So we're adding social media.
Doctors wanna brand themselves,
wanna advertise.
Just like you create a profile
on Rolodoc
and create a profile
on another social network,
but those social networks
aren't safe.
You can't--You don't--
(Mark) Okay, wait.
Take a step back.
How am I gonna convince you,
the physician,
to put your profile up there
and detail
the services that you offer?
Well, that's easy. There's
800,000 U.S. Physicians--
No, I didn't ask
what the market was.
Okay.
There's a hundred places
to put profiles.
What are you going to do
to convince doctors...
just like you have
business connections,
we have medical connections.
We're gonna launch in Arizona,
texas, and chicago. Those are
where all our connections are.
Doing what? Doing what?
We--we have access
to multiple doctors,
multiple databases.
We're gonna tell 'em
that this is the best way
to brand yourself
in advertising.
How are you going to
tell them?
I'm pulling teeth.
I should be a dentist.
Are you personally--
You're gonna quit your practice,
you're gonna stop doing surgery,
and you're gonna make the call?
No, this day and age,
we can do it with electronics.
We can e-Mail--
(Lori) You can--
buy a database?
You know what, mark, though?
And send an e-Mail?
This is dangerous. How are you
vetting these doctors?
It's a valid concern, 'cause
you don't wanna be reading
about somebody that actually
isn't a surgeon...
right.
That's offering heart surgery.
That would be a bad outcome.
Absolutely.
I don't think they're
gonna get anybody.
It's not gonna be dangerous
if you can't get any doctors.
Okay, let's go through
the logical progression.
Yeah.
My doctor gets an e-mail.
"Oh, it's from Rolodoc!"
"Never heard of 'em."
Delete.
(Kevin) Wait a second.
You haven't explained
how I make money,
which is
the most important thing.
My doctor is very hip
to technology.
Why would he use this,
and how would I profit
from him actually
getting on board?
He's gonna use this
'cause he's gonna want
to attract new Patients,
provide social media
to the medical field--
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
You guys are driving me nuts.
Wait. Let him answer!
How do I make money?
No, but he keeps on saying
"Social media, social media."
This is all one-to-One
communication.
You're not gonna let him
tell me how I make money.
'cause there's no chance
of you making money on this.
Do--is that the answer?
Targeted advertising is how
you're gonna make your money.
Within a secure environment,
you're gonna do
targeted Advertising?
Uh, not gonna happen.
Well, you can de--
Look, there are social networks
that are already doing this
for physician-only mobile--
Mobile networks.
Within just
physician-to-physician...
correct.
Which has a whole different
set of security issues
than communicating
with patients.
Correct.
But you can target
the physicians.
I see this as
a liability nightmare.
Because you are putting
people in touch
with their doctors.
They're answering back without
maybe seeing a patient,
knowing what's going on.
This is just my opinion.
There's a lot of risk in it.
I'm out.
What we're trying to do
is we're trying to bring
social media to medicine.
And you--
Albert, let me go back
to mark's point.
The current social network--
You keep saying
"Social Media"...
Yeah.
Then you go to e-mail.
E-mail is not social media.
Doctors are constantly
posting things
on twitter
and on other web sites.
And how do you use that?
Well, that's what we have.
We have the capability
of being a social network.
Instead of saying,
"Follow me on x-x site,"
you say,
"Follow me on Rolodoc."
I get that you're trying
to recreate twitter
and facebook on to Rolodoc.
Correct.
Okay, but I want to do this
eye-to-eye, face-to-face,
'cause you're doctors.
Worst presentation ever.
I'm out.
(Robert) Oh, that was mean.
Ever. You guys should be
smart enough to know.
You didn't show us
any of the social media.
You showed us profiles
and talked to us about e-mail.
You didn't tell us at all
how you were gonna get there.
It was horrible.
(Robert) Mark, I just think
you're being a bully.
I mean, they might be
misguided--
Okay, I am being a bully.
Then they deserve
to be bullied.
(Barbara) It's hurtful
to watch you.
I would have to agree with mark.
I think it was the worst
sales presentation I've heard.
We're not presenters, okay?
We're physicians, so--
But guess what.
I don't care
what your background is.
If you're looking for money,
you got to sell your idea.
That business plan
is so unclear,
I'm out.
(Robert) With all due respect,
I just don't think
you've explained
how you're gonna get users,
how you're gonna monetize it.
I just don't see the business.
I'm out.
(Kevin) I was intrigued.
Frankly, it's depressing,
'cause I like new ideas
in the medical space.
They're forever if they work.
But at the end of the day,
I can't connect the dots
regarding how I make money.
I'm out.
Fair enough. Thank you.
Thanks.
Thank you, all.
♪♪
It's okay, man. It's okay.
They just weren't prepared.
They were arrogant,
thinking that they were just
gonna be able to wing it...
(snaps fingers)
and everybody's gonna get it.
Mark, they weren't arrogant.
Oh, yes, they were.
They just didn't know
any better.
It's our baby, man.
Can't give up on our baby.
We're kind of bummed out,
you know?
I was expecting to be able
to portray it
a little bit better
than we really did.
Yeah.
Protein is never wasted
when a death occurs.
Just--
What does that mean?
It means that others
will see what happened here,
they'll learn
from their mistakes,
so they won't make
the same mistake.
I don't mind sacrificing
a couple of doctors
if it means the next two doctors
can make me money.
That's what I'm saying.
They--You know, they were
right about one thing.
What?
You have no heart.
♪♪
Next into the tank
are two entrepreneurs
from Dallas, Texas,
hoping to bring
a little bit of sweetness
to the masses.
♪♪
Hello, sharks.
My name is Cole Egger.
And my name
is James Mcdonald,
and our product
is Sweet Ballz.
(laughs)
That's right. Sweet Ballz.
We're here today seeking
$250,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company.
Everyone loves
a fresh cake ball,
but very few are interested
in spending
the hours it takes
to create them.
Sharks, so what we did is take
an already-popular product,
the cake pop,
and we gave it a makeover...
simply by removing the stick,
creating a 4-pack,
as well as creating
a quality cake ball
to bring to the masses.
The best part about
our cake balls, sharks--
They sell for a fraction
of the cost
of most local bakery
cake balls.
But before we go any further,
we'd like to pass out
a few samples for you to try.
I hate you already.
(laughs)
Bring on the Sweet Ballz.
James, what are
the different flavors?
(James) Our sexy red velvet
needs no introduction.
(Barbara) Mmm!
These mind-blowing cake balls...
yummy.
Have the savory cake
on the inside
and a decadent icing
on the outside.
(Lori) It's very fudgy.
(James)
Our chocolate Sweet Ballz
are dipped in
milk chocolate Icing
and taste like the cake
that your mama used to make.
My mama?
And our cookies n' cream
Sweet Ballz--
More like cookies and scream,
the way these taste.
These are good.
So which one of you sharks
are ready
to make some sweet,
sweet dough
with our Sweet Ballz?
(laughs)
I have a question.
Okay.
You talked a lot
about cake pops.
The ones I have tried...
Mm-hmm.
Weren't really very good.
Sure.
These are very cakey
and very moist.
What's your shelf life?
Uh, we actually have
a 45-day shelf life
for the product, which is
pretty unique because--
Un-Refrigerated?
Un-Refrigerated.
So what were your sales
last month?
Uh, actually,
in the last 90 days,
we've done
$700,000 in sales.
Wow!
(Kevin) Say what?
Where are you selling?
No one expected that.
I wasn't expecting that.
(Lori) No.
(Robert) and where
did you sell that?
Uh, it'd be the largest
convenience store
in the United States.
7-Eleven?
7-Eleven.
Wow!
You sell these at 7-Eleven?
Yes.
So what does one 4-pack
sell for?
It retails anywhere
from $1.99 to $2.49.
(Barbara) Really?
Oh, that's nothing.
So $1.99. There you go.
(Robert) Wow.
That's why there's--Okay.
What does it cost you
to make them?
Uh, currently it costs us
86 cents to make.
86 cents.
It's like a dream come True
for a young business to walk in
and get a huge order like that.
How did that come about?
(James) Well,
we both have experience
bringing items to retail.
Me, I used to work
in sports marketing
around the Dallas area.
Uh, and after that, I started
working for a manufacturer.
I really learned the--
The, uh, retail side of things.
But you didn't work for the best
team in the Dallas area, right?
The best team's the Mavericks,
no doubt.
(Robert) Now how about Cole?
Where did you work?
Uh, I've actually been
a-a serial entrepreneur
all my life.
(speaks indistinctly)
Cole, did you have a product
in this kind of
retail environment before?
Uh, I-I've worked in the frozen
food product, uh, category, yes.
Were any of your other
enterprises successful?
Uh, successful as, uh...
where you make money,
the only thing that matters.
(laughter)
Um, I--we have. I mean, we've
had a couple different companies
that have--Have made money.
Um, unfortunately for us,
we didn't have
the right partnership
or we weren't able to raise
the capital that we needed
to help grow the business.
So you got burned
along the way, maybe,
learned some lessons--
which is a good thing.
Bad thing, to get burned
along the way--
It doesn't matter
how many times you fail.
You just have to be right
one time.
At what percentage
of your sales is 7-Eleven?
About 95%.
Ohh!
Doesn't it scare
the Sweet Ballz off you
that you have 95% of your sales
with one retailer?
It's a great point,
and we've--We've been
making strides and working--
We just got a-another P.O.
Not only are we in
the largest convenience store,
but we're also in
the largest distributor--
The two largest distributors
set up.
(Robert) Cole, on the million
in sales you'll do this year,
will you make a profit?
We've made $95,000
to date.
Okay, James, things--Things
are going great for you.
Why are you here?
Because for us,
it's about growth.
Right now one of the things
we have is a 21-Day turnaround.
The $250,000 would be used
to offset
some of our inventory needs
so that we could get away
from that 21-day lead time,
'cause some of the retailers
that we've talked to right now
want to be able to turn it
faster than 21 days.
So you're asking for $250,000
for 25%?
For 10% of the company.
(laughter)
(Kevin) Yeah--
Here's what's wrong
with the 10%--
Nobody gets excited
about 10%.
Understood.
Nobody's interested in 10%.
What, uh... what would
get you interested?
Oh, big numbers. 80%, 90%.
(laughing)
Oh, yeah.
That works for me, too.
Is that your offer, Barbara?
$250,000 for 90%?
(Lori) 90%?
Hey, I'll give you an offer.
I'll give you $250,000
for 40%.
Ba-Bam!
Okay.
Thank you for the offer, too.
(laughs)
(Robert)
Ah, very nice, James.
Well, it's not--You know,
not saying it's, you know,
directly no, but thank you
for the offer.
Do you guys want
to consult on that?
Well...
(laughter)
Or the--hopefully
there's, uh,
at least one other offer
out there.
Have you paid yourself
anything?
Uh, we have.
We've taken a distribution.
How big is your distribution?
Uh, amounts to roughly
$2,500, $3,000 a month.
(Kevin) I like it,
'cause it's close to a space
I'm very involved in now,
particularly the commercial
kitchen logistics side.
Wicked Good Cupcakes--
We're making a lot of money
in that company.
I'll do the $250,000 for 30%,
but here is the covenant
that I'm gonna put on it,
because I'm concerned in all
the food deals I've ever done
in getting my capital back
before I die.
Sure.
So when you make
a distribution,
I get one, too--
Dollar for dollar.
So I'm just like a partner
that started at the top,
except I paid a whole lot more
for it.
We-We'd like to also know,
like, which retailer
you--You have
relationships at
that you could also help us
get into.
I can call any retailer
and get my call returned.
Well, that's not necessarily so.
What I--what I've learned--
what I've learned
about this business--
That's not always true
of him.
What I've learned about
this business--
"Hi, it's Kevin O'Leary."
Click.
(chuckles)
I like Kevin's offer...
except--
There's one problem.
You don't like Kevin.
(laughs)
I like Kevin a lot.
Well, I don't like Kevin,
so I'll just admit it.
I like Kevin's offer,
but I'm going to change it
a little bit.
Okay.
$250,000 for 36%
and the same distribution
that Kevin offered.
But I'm bringing with me
not only retail,
which I'm known
for lightning speed...
absolutely.
But I also bring with me qvc.
And...
I've got good news for you.
I'll keep my offer--
I can do hundreds
of thousands of dollars
in minutes.
Right.
We'll call in, and they will--
anybody that's got a product
that can sell...
You know what?
Can sell it on qvc.
I would agree with that.
Yes, and you know how many
people last?
Very few.
I will tell you--
to survive on qvc
is a very tricky thing.
You have to really
know what you're doing.
Mm-hmm.
As Barbara will attest to.
I'll attest to it, but let me
tell you something.
It's only in adjunct sales.
Right.
It's not the main deal.
Sure.
You've got the main deal.
It's free advertising
and great sales.
It's free advertising,
and the theory is,
is that it drives other sales,
and I have found
in testing that theory
there's no truth to it.
Oh, that's not True at all.
James, when you have Lori
and Barbara on the panel...
Wait, wait, wait.
I c--
You can't get a word in
edgewise.
(laughter)
So, James, I'll give you
the $250,000 for 25%.
And I-I don't need a royalty
or anything along the way.
I mean, my gosh,
you've done a million dollars
in your first year in sales.
Let me come along
for that ride.
Okay.
Thank you.
Robert, and I'm sure
you bring a retailer
to the table as well, from--
I can certainly bring costco,
but, you know, frankly,
I'm sure everybody here could.
But I'm not investing
in my retail strategy.
(James) Mm-hmm.
I'm investing
in the two of you guys.
Mm-hmm.
(Lori) You need a shark
that knows how to keep you
in the retailer.
Because it's--We can get in,
we can break down the door.
Some of us, I think
more doors than others.
Don't sell yourself short.
But--No.
(Lori) I think
some more than others.
But you also have to think
about who--What strategic
partner do you want.
(lowered voice)
I like these guys,
but I don't know the cake
and Candy business like you do.
Is it somebody who has
a lot of experience,
creativity, can get you
into a lot of stores?
You're making me blush.
Stop.
No, I mean--
(laughter)
You know, you have to think
about it in your gut.
Sure.
Well, let me ask one question.
Mark...
um, is there a potential
for an offer on the table?
Yeah, I'm interested.
I think I'd rather have
a strategic partner with me...
sure.
Than do it on my own.
So I'd like to work
with Barbara.
Um, I like
Barbara's experience there.
Barbara, you had some ideas
on what you wanted to do,
so fire away.
Yeah, I had offered you 40%,
and I obviously know
I've been out-Priced here.
I'm gonna adjust my offer,
but I have a feeling
that I'm working with
a generous partner here,
and I'm afraid--
and so keep your mouth shut.
I always pay--they say I overpay
all the time.
Keep your mouth shut.
What are you gonna say?
He overpays, all right?
I'll adjust the offer
to 33%,
because the truth
of the matter is--
That's not what we discussed.
The offer is 25%. Right?
Thirty--
Wait, wait, wait.
No, we didn't agree on 25%.
Yes, we did. Yes, we did.
No, we didn't.
I said I'd think about it.
Whoa. You--
do you want two partners
can't even agree
on the offer?
He just
thought about it.
Think about it.
(Barbara)
No, I didn't want to do that.
(Mark) You didn't want
to do 25%?
This is really interesting.
(Barbara) No. All right, 30%,
all right.
I'm going along with him
'cause he's so damn pushy.
Okay, I'll agree to $250,000
for your 25%.
(Robert) 25%. So you've got
an offer from Barbara and mark
for $250,000 for 25%,
so would you agree with me
there's value
in having more than one shark
in the deal?
Absolutely.
Yes.
All right, well, what if you
had three sharks
with the same offer?
♪♪
All the sharks
have offers on the table,
but Robert senses he may need
to collude with Lori and Kevin
in order to compete with
an offer from Mark and Barbara.
So you've got an offer
from Barbara and mark
for $250,000 for 25%.
So what if you had three sharks
with the same offer?
I'm willing to work
with Lori and that Kevin guy.
I think three sharks are
worth more than two.
Kevin's the only guy
that's actually done
one of these deals.
I like it. I like it.
But I'm willing
to match this offer
if these guys come in with me--
$250,000 for 25%,
and we get the same
distribution.
I think I can bring you retail
that you don't have today.
I definitely can.
I think she can bring you
another channel.
And... Kevin adds value.
(laughter)
How original.
(Kevin) I think
you have to adjust it.
I'll tell you why.
You got three sharks here.
We should get 10% each
at least.
So are--is--are these
the final offers on the table?
(Robert) All right,
$250,000.
Okay.
We're at 30%.
For 30%.
(Cole) okay.
They're at 25%.
(Robert) same distribution.
You get three sharks,
two sharks.
Same distribution.
And everybody has connections.
The more sharks you have,
the more connections you get.
It's that simple.
And in reality,
the differentiation is,
they're not gonna walk you
into theater chains,
into food service for arenas
and for stadiums.
Well, yes, we are.
I'm not sure that's true.
Because we're gonna
walk you...
that's ridiculous.
Into any chain that they
can walk you into.
When I have something that we
want to have sold in our arena,
we say, "Sell this."
when I have something that we
want sold in my theaters,
I say, "Sell this."
and that's great, except--
but--
That's great for one Arena.
That's great--Yeah.
I think there's more Arenas--
That's 5% of the market.
And you need
really great advertising.
And I will tell you,
regardless of what Barbara said,
I know from 17 years
of experience
that absolutely people are dying
to get on qvc
for publicity alone.
Qvc is lights, cameras,
customers--like that.
(Kevin) You've got every shark.
This is so rare
in the shark tank,
where you got everybody
involved.
♪♪
Three is better than two.
What are you going to do?
♪♪
In a perfect world,
we'd love to be
partners with all you guys,
'cause you all bring
so much to the table.
Y'all really are great.
Kevin, Lori, Robert...
think it's
a fantastic opportunity
knowing what you bring
to the table,
but I think as of today,
we'll have to go
with Mark and Barbara.
Oh!
Yes, sir!
(Barbara) Yes!
Sweet Ballz fans for life!
Yes, sir!
F.F.L., baby! (laughing)
Appreciate it.
You're a smart guy.
Thank you.
I could feel the ballz
slipping away.
(Barbara) Pleasure...
Appreciate it, ma'am.
Congratulations, guys.
Blah, blah, blah, blah!
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
(laughter)
(Robert) Nice job.
(whispers) Yes, sir!
Was there ever a doubt?
I'm very surprised.
I think they made a mistake.
Yeow! Yes, sir!
Sweet Ballz
coming to A.A.C., baby!
Let's go! That's what
I'm talking about!
Excuse me. Who's hot?
Who's hot?
(laughing)
Who's hot? Who's hot?
(Lori speaks indistinctly)
Who's hot?
(Kevin) I think--
Lord...